now that was the scene as longtime Trump
associate Roger stone left his
arraignment this afternoon he pled not
guilty to charges stemming from the
Muller probe just five days since his
home was swarmed by dozens of FBI agents
and a pre-dawn raid now in his first
television interview since being
arraigned Roger stone joins us live
Roger you've now had a busy few days to
say the least
on Sunday you told Stephanopoulos that
you would be open perhaps too cool
cooperating with Muller but just
yesterday you seemed to change your tune
what's going on which is it yeah I think
that my comments and ABC may have been
misconstrued what I meant was I'm not
going to bear false witness against
anybody I'm going to tell the truth
under oath into the investigators if
they have questions subject obviously to
the advice format wise of my attorneys
but I'm not going to do what Michael
Kohn has done I'm not going to make up
lies or bear false witness against
Donald Trump or anyone else the truth of
the matter is that even though I'm
accused of lying when I get Adam Schiff
on the stand when I get Eric's wawel on
this day and when I get other members of
that committee I understand I'll
demonstrate that they're the ones who
are lying not me your old pal jerome
corsi was on with martha maccallum
earlier tonight and had a warning for
you let's watch is they are extremely
thorough they have everything Roger
shouldn't underestimate that every
communication he had telephone email who
he met with in person the Mueller team
has spent enormous they have endless
resources so Roger should go in this
fully prepared understanding that he's
not going to be able to dodge the
evidence that I'm sure Mueller has your
reaction to that well unfortunately dr.
Corsi has already said a couple things
about me that are demonstrably not true
unfortunately well for example that a
memo he wrote me regarding the Podesta
brothers lucrative business dealings in
Russia based on public reports published
by Peters
serve both the New York Post and a
Breitbart was somehow a cover story a
cover story for what what would there be
to cover up my tweet the Podesta
brothers was not controversial for six
weeks dr. Corsi said he told me that he
told me that John Podesta emails had
been stolen on Tucker Carlson he said he
told many people that with Ari member
not really a journalist he said he's
told everybody that well he never told
me that and maybe he can tell us who
else he told he also said that I knew
about the Billy Bush NBC tape in advance
and I directed him to contact Julian
Assange and tell him to move up or
change the the dump of data to distract
from that whole cloth unfortunately for
dr. Corsi I have text messages and
emails and matted metadata that shows
that he's not telling us I know you're
told you've already said you haven't
deleted any that's correct emails from
any email address that he's ever had any
physical documents have they ever been
destroyed by no no absolutely not now it
is true that I forgot that I had text
messages in an old cellphone that are
entirely culpa Tory which prove
definitively that Randy critical was my
source as to the content not the content
is that one of the false statements that
you made yes that would be one of the
false statements but the text messages
prove that credit course as to the
significance in the October release date
of the WikiLeaks right we had talked
about that on radio as well at the time
now there any look we all forget things
but these are pretty given the nature of
this investigation might you have
forgotten other things to the extent
that I made mistakes of memory they
would be without intent and they would
be inconsequential they would not be
material under the law for any legal
expert to look at these little excerpts
without reading four and a half hours of
testimony to see the context the
questions before and the questions after
would be irresponsible but you can watch
CNN and see this indictment is a slam
dunk my attorneys don't think so a
former FBI assistant director Frank fig
illuzzi was talking about
your only hope now being a pardon let's
watch I'm a strong advocate of the
theory that stone is positioning himself
for a pardon and that it's likely the
only hope he has he seems driven and
motivated merely by absolute publicity
absolutely being in the center of things
regardless of whether it's bad publicity
or good publicity he needs to be there
and he seems to be shaded toward the
negative is that it your only path out
according to these characters on TV you
know caring to talk to the president
through our show to get a pardon I don't
know many FBI agents who know much about
politics or public relations or the law
in many cases the truth of the matter is
if you read my book stones rules
I believe when you're falsely accused of
something and you say nothing you say no
comment or Roger stone was unavailable
most Americans assume you're guilty the
whole purpose of this over-the-top raid
on my house in which they sent in more
men than were used to protect our
compound in Benghazi was to paint a
picture of me to poison a jury with
several public enemy number it was one
of the more ridiculous things and it was
offensive it's offensive to me
regardless of what goes down here that
it was like Elian Gonzalez times times
29 or times 28 it was absurd all right
we also have your friend over at MSNBC
Mika Brzezinski yes who was making a
point about your claim that your dog was
terrorized you how many dogs you have
but I have two dogs and what kind their
Yorkshire Terrier okay your keys okay
and they get terrorized easily they do
they can they're they're a little yappy
I love them but they're yappy
all right this is what she said stones
complained that his dogs were terrorized
is also a tiny bit ironic because his
seven count indictment includes the
allegation that stone tried to
intimidate someone by threatening their
therapy dog why don't do that what
number one Randi credit goes dog is not
registered in New York as a therapy dog
number two he wasn't feeding the dog
perhaps because he was spending his
money on other things and that was the
Conte
once again you take something out of
context and it has a different meaning
you can go to the Daily Caller and read
the articles I've written about war
animal welfare and ending the the humane
medical testing on dogs and cats I mean
I know this about right Roger is a very
Pro animal person like I am and that is
one you could say you're dirty
tricksters and are you gonna do the
Nixon piece on for every appearance by
the way no not necessarily be sure it's
button I think we got it
well when I was arrested I was wearing
my Roger stone did nothing wrong t-shirt
of course you can buy them it's at at
1776 by the way by the way Pompeyo says
that WikiLeaks is a non-state hostile
intelligence service why would you work
with them why would you want anything
could I see the proof of that please
which where's the judicial decision that
says that I'm afraid our intelligence
services have been politicized John
Brennan says the same thing I don't
believe it to be true so it's a claim
it's never been proved in the US court
of law talk about the Russia having
actually gotten in we don't know that
first of all everyone concludes that but
they just kind of pronounced it but
right right to talking point but it's
unproven in a court of law and I don't
believe it's true I think Julian Assange
who was interviewed by Sean Hannity is a
journalist he does the same thing the
New York Times in the Washington Post in
the Wall Street Journal do Roger will be
watching we'll be watching when's your
next appearance I actually will probably
come on with Tucker later in the week
okay Lori in the podcast tomorrow yes
indeed all right that's what you're
trying to get you to say that Roger
thanks so much